each small square in the diagram has a
side length of one centimeter
so what is the area of the figure
so we have this figure down here in blue
and we want to know its area area is the
total space it covers
and we're also told that each of these
little squares has a side length of one
centimeter
so that means each of these squares is
one square centimeter
so we can find the area by seeing how
many square centimeters does this figure
cover
one way
would be just to try to draw the little
square centimeters and count them
there's one square centimeter there's
two and so on and keep counting them
all the way through
or
what we could do is we could look at
this and try to break it into two
shapes so we can say down here
into two rectangles down here we have
one rectangle
and up here we have a second rectangle
and then we can find the area of each
rectangle and add it together to find
the total area that the figure covers
down here on the bottom we have two rows
of unit squares and each of those has
one two three four five six seven
so one two three four five six seven
so there's two rows
of seven unit squares or seven square
centimeters so the bottom rectangle
is made up of 14
square centimeters
it covers 14 square centimeters and the
top rectangle let's see we have one row
two
three
four
five rows
and each of those rows has one two
square centimeters so we have five rows
of two square centimeters or 10.
so this top rectangle here that we have
in blue
covers 10 square centimeters
plus
the bottom rectangle that we outlined in
green
covers 14 square centimeters
so in total
the entire figure covers 24
square
centimeters
so 24 square centimeters is our area
because area is how much space does it
cover
and we figured out that it covered 24
square centimeters